Phil's question was there are a lot of
different joke writing books available
what are your top three that have helped
you the most
now with this question
people should know
we did a whole comedy author Series
where we literally interviewed all the
top comedy authors basically if you go
on Amazon and you search comedy writing
books all the top authors we interviewed
we put together like in order a comedy
author series and then had like a recap
episode talking about all the big
takeaways from all these different
comedy authors so if you thought hot
breath was the best comedy resource it
just got even better with that context
for y'all to know because nobody's doing
that
um but for sure
the one I've read cover to cover
yeah and the one that I started with is
and this is like joke writing books not
like Steve Martin's biography or
anything like that but the one I read
cover to cover and that taught me
one-liners is Greg Dean's step by step
to stand up that's okay it's the book I
started with if you're looking to learn
one-liners and you don't want to take
our five steps to funny workshop for
whatever reason
um it's available Linked In the show
notes then that's a good book that'll
help you do that
um so one-liners yeah that's solid uh
the I've read
all the comedy books that I've probably
read maybe like five or six but I would
say the top one for me in terms of like
started out with and have went back to
the revised version of this book Judy
Carter's comedy Bible freaking godsend
of a book it is so well structured uh
just the prompts are amazing in it
um I'm also going to give a shout out to
uh somebody else you've had on the
podcast
um Jerry corley's uh sort of like
architecture book on the 13 archetypes
of a joke uh he's got this entire
um breakdown of jokes it's in a PDF
format I think it's in a book format
that is like a hundred and something
Pages freaking amazing resource so those
are breaking comedy DNA one
yes
Brandon Lee coming in with that one yeah
yeah that is legit one of the best
straight up like practical uh joke
writing technique books that I've ever
ever read I've one of my best jokes came
out of using those exercises that still
kills till today
um so yeah those are those probably the
be like if I was to say three yeah I I
also agree with Greg Danes like I've
read that one too just just good like
it's just a good on one-liners here to
your point but it's like the setup of
the of just getting to the highlights of
jokes and things like that that book is
awesome
yeah that's a solid top three so uh Greg
Dean step by step to stand up in no
particular order I think this is how we
brought them up but Greg Dean step by
step to stand up
you said Judy Carter is the comedy Bible
and Jared corley's breaking comedies DNA
I think that's a solid that's a solid
top three there
there's plenty of others I would you
know uh go out and check them out but I
think you know if I was to say there's
those three I can always kind of like go
back to try different exercises like I
go back to Greg Dean's exercises as well
and Judy Carter's when I'm writing like
new topics and the way that they do
their uh prompts writing prompts both of
them have writing prompts that are just
really really good if you're exploring
like a brand new topic as well which I
think is awesome
and speaking of writing prompts goodness
every day on our Facebook group
Bobby Sutton posts a new word every
single day it's the right Ten Club
10 a.m eastern time every single day
Bobby's posting a new word for you to
just write a joke about post it in there
get feedback from other people read
other people's jokes share some feedback
it's a great it's kind of like it's like
Wordle for comedians